роман сутенко офіційну шпигун з точкою
зору російської прокуратури
журналіст над ти чекав відвезли co2 від
вух зем все так давай тут все так
розумі це все ту ж складно черви вали
година не адвокатами може пройти до своїх
підзахисних ціни види про складну за
багаттям anna sushchenko ти мені менше
адвокат журналіста вірити опери ногу у
темних російському судді а на
міжнародному рівні ви розумію ми
розуміємо ще праворуч прошу хамство
розслідується в державі століття та великі
проблеми з правом та люди на політичному
і свободам і свободам і змі і тим більше
правосуддям піти ж ми ще вибрати
інструмент як на граматику думку за
худу tayima жвавості тому завис але ми
навіть розкрадаємо ще на зал і шитись
байдуже ми європейські організації то
рязанова роду завзятого дружини політики
якi мають на світ моніторять цю праворуч
ще нам я нехай все ж таки допоможе api
та агрегати європейські політики діваються
що журналіста від росія знову
наступаючи на ті ж граблі
засихання на свободу слова аж ній від нас
при я з препарату Москви то брюсселя
на поки голова комітету закруглених
справа європарламенту вбити а я ззаду
це в сезон зовні були ти чого жили для
звір нанесу щеня але сенс
а саме відсоток раба говорить і всім
рівнях і ціни на карист русі та ще
справа на буду публічності ван йому
ситнов 4 рахунку складно рахунки критика на
і ковані нарожаю dso nano кори
стогне не прогнути від риму ти судиш
років можливо активні за винизами
чого вона не може просто вигляд ключі ти
свободу думки
ще c по поганому для росії у що в
цієї такі акції торкнуться але люди
задумалися справа роману сутенко вхід
рази свічки на євро їжі русія шахрая
журналістику це шпигунство батька
удар по свободі слова